hallo mein name ist vanessa und ich bin
überfordert maßlos überfordert ich habe
gerade das ganze intro für dieses video
gedreht habe die kamera aus gemacht und
mir ist aufgefallen dass was du sagen
wolltest konntest du nicht so rüber
bringen weil du eine maske auf hat ist
und trotzdem so tun wollte es einfach
alles supi ist ich weiß der videothek
klingt jetzt nicht so dramatisch wie
dieses video hier anfängt trotzdem
glaube ich dass ist die ehrlichste art
ist dieses video hier anzufangen indem
ich einfach mal talk mit euch machen und
sage ich arbeite zu viel es ist schwer
als youtuber zu sagen ich arbeite zu
viel weil ich weiß dass es da draußen
sehr viel mehr leute gibt die auch zu
viel arbeiten die aber es nicht so sagen
können und man glaubt immer noch dass
youtuber eigentlich den ganzen tag nur
zu hause rum chillen ab und zu sich vor
die kamera setzen und das dann zusammen
schneiden und dann war es besonders
social media trägt einen großen teil
dazu bei warum man sich glaube ich
überfordert fühlt denn unser gehirn
bekommt viel zu viele eindrücke durch
youtube-videos in stars stories mr
videos die man sich zum einschlafen
anschaut auch wenn man nicht arbeitet
arbeitet unser gehirn ich habe letztens
irgendwo gelesen dass man verlernt hat
sich zu langweilen obwohl das langweilen
an sich sehr positiv fürs gehirn ist
denn da schaltet es ab und kann halt
neue ideen neue kreativität freisetzen
ich hab das zum ganzen das beispiel als
ich im fitnessstudio gearbeitet habe
stand ich immer am empfang und musste
nur die leute begrüßen und ab und zu
vertrag mit denen
abschließend und es war die
langweiligste arbeit die ich jemals
hatte gleichzeitig bekam ich aber
während dieser zeit immer die besten
ideen für ihr video ja ich habe während
meiner youtube karriere schon so einige
jobs gehabt und mir wurde vor kurzem
eine kooperation vorgeschlagen und zwar
mit dem kindle paper white
ich dachte mir zuerst ja lesen ist jetzt
nicht so mein ding ich habe nicht viel
mit lesen am hut und ich glaube auch
nicht dass die leute sich für lese
videos interessieren
dann kam aber der gedanke dass das
vielleicht genau auch der schlüssel ist
warum ich mich so gefordert fühlen weil
ich mir nicht mal mehr zeit nehmen für
so banale sachen wie lesen denn in der
zeit in der ich lesen kann kann ich auch
ganz viele andere dinge schaffen e mails
beantworten in stars stories machen ins
dass dies von anderen leuten anschauen
youtube videos machen youtube videos
anschauen
ich weiß dass es viele youtube - da
draußen gibt die mich auch abschalten
lassen bei denen ich einfach spaß daran
habt sie zuschauen
trotzdem ist es doch was anderes immer
sich von diesem bewegten bildern
bescheid zu lassen besonders bevor man
schlafen geht das mache ich in letzter
zeit so oft dass ich noch bis 1 uhr
nachts mir irgend welche youtube videos
auf dem handy anschauen und dann im
nachhinein merkel hey ich werde gar
nicht müde das liegt daran dass der
bildschirm so hell ist dass die augen
die ganze denken na ja sie hat noch
tageslicht und dann ins gehirn versendet
wird wir müssen noch nicht müde werden
anders ist es beim lesen gewesen wenn
ich früher gelesen habe dann habe ich
fünf seiten von schlafengehen gelesen
und war schon so müde dass ich noch
weggekippt bin diese zeit wünsche ich
mir irgendwie wieder zurück deswegen
möchte ich wie ihr auch ein video tätig
diesen habt so viele youtuber bücher wie
möglich in einer woche schaffen
natürlich hat das jetzt wieder so ein
challenge faktor brauche ich aber auch
ein bisschen um mich wirklich daran zu
halten ich habe jetzt diesen kinder per
post zugeschickt bekommen um dieses
projekt zu starten und ja ich muss sagen
er ist wirklich sehr leicht und er ist
sogar wasserdicht und man kann die
schriftgröße ändern und man kann es auch
als hörbuch benutzen wenn man mit
bluetooth kopfhörer dann kann man
zwischen lesen und hören switchen und in
dieser woche in der ich nur mit dem
kindle bücher von youtube an lesen
möchte habe ich mich auch dazu
entschlossen social media mal beiseite
zu legen
und mal wieder runter zu kommen wenn zum
beispiel burnout ist ein thema was jetzt
auf youtube schon länger die runde macht
was ich für mich nicht so sehen konnte
weil ich immer dachte ja nee ist ja ganz
entspannt so das leben macht spaß
besonders aber in den letzten wochen
habe ich gemerkt dass man sich doch
schnell in der arbeit verlieren kann
beziehen sollte in dem stress indem man
sie jemand selber mal das ist für mich
gerade so das tor zur entspannung ich
freue mich so auf die woche jetzt kommt
das ist jetzt zum montagmittag ich
möchte das nächste woche montag viele
bücher lesen ich habe mir auch schon bei
youtube bücher ausgesucht
es gibt von luca dass die biografie von
seinem jungen leben
lutens buch das muss ich natürlich lesen
von meinem schatz minuten
michael buchner hat zum beispiel auch
ein neues buch herausgebracht scorpion
hat drei hart geschrieben und jetzt mit
zange lux zusammen flockhart ich muss
sagen darauf bin ich auch sehr gespannt
ich hoffe dass ich viele bücher schaffe
also tatsächlich auch so lange jetzt
nicht mehr gelesen dass ich das gar
nicht einschätzen kann wie viel man in
einer woche scharf schreibt mal in die
kommentare wie viel schafft ihr in einer
woche zu lesen ist das würde mich mal
interessieren mirallas buch was jetzt am
30 november rauskommt schleichwerbung
ist leider noch nicht verfügbar deswegen
kann ich das noch nicht lesen aber der
rest wird von mir durch genommen und
sogar kollege hat ein buch
herausgebracht
die zehn gebote oder so ich weiß es
sitzt nicht wirklich in youtube aber
schon irgendwie im entferntesten sinne
ich meine videopreise
eigentlich macht ihn das schon zum
youtube ich glaube ich fange mit dem
buch von michael buchinger an denn ich
interessiere mich wirklich dafür was er
zu sagen hat
ich bin immer noch großartig lustig wir
könnten auch seinen kanal aufschrecken
falls ihr nicht kennt einfach ein toller
typ also wenn der nicht ruhiger und ein
freund hätte michael wir bei michaels
buch heißt lange beine kurze lügen und
jetzt gehts los mit dem projekt
bücherwurm 3 2 1
ich habe jetzt eine stunde bett gelesen
und werde so müde davon
ich habe jetzt auch erstmal das licht
angemacht weil es immer dunkler wurde
draußen und ich muss sagen michael
buchinger du bist so ein guter autor es
macht so spaß dieses buch zu lesen fall
erst einfach so schafft so eine lustige
art zu schreiben hat er über seinen
alkoholkonsum gesprochen und über sein
mauritius urlaub
das macht einfach mega spaß ich merke
ich dass ich ein bisschen unruhig werde
weil ich schon ganz nicht auf mein handy
geschaut hab nicht weiß ob mir jemand
geschrieben habe
wie soll ich das schaffe so im kopf
abzuschalten
doch ist jetzt kann ich den kindle paper
richtig gut in velen nie wirklich also
wirklich wirklich wirklich tolles
geräten ich kann damit echt und lesen
meine augen tun gar nicht wen ich werde
nur einfach müde vom lesen
ich hab mir grad eine gemüsesuppe
aufgewertet und wollte dabei schön
youtube videos schauen so wie ich das
immer mache
und jetzt wo es mir quasi verbiete merke
ich wie ich mich dauerbeschuss
also werde ich jetzt hier sitzen und
einfach meine suppe ohne mein handy in
der hand zu haben ohne youtube an zu
machen einfach nur essen und dann weiter
lesen ich bin eingeschlafen
lesen macht auf jeden fall sehr sehr
müde aber ich bin immer noch der meinung
dass es sich vor lohnt 43 prozent vom
buch habe ich schon durchgewesen ändern
wird
so setzt 23 uhr ist fertig zu machen und
ich habe auch die haut haben dass ich
heute das nicht ein buch in dem buch
durch bekomme
es ist fantastisch hat sogar von
seinerzeit aus berlin erzählt aber dass
du dich nicht erwähnt ich meine ich mir
auch mal besucht naja ich hab mir jetzt
spannend gemacht und bis morgen
lass meine toilette guten morgen es ist
9 uhr gibt s nicht gestern durch
geschafft ich bin bei 95 prozent also
ich bin fast durch mit dem ich habe in
einer stunde einen wichtigen call aber
derzeit schafft das buch erwähnt
bester abschlusssatz liebe leserinnen
und liebe leser ich hoffe wirklich ihr
hattet spaß und dieses buch hat euch
gefallen und wenn dem nicht so war lud
mich doch bitte einfach an
ich hab das jetzt schon die ganze zeit
gesagt aber mich ist buch ist wirklich
eine absolute empfehlung lange beine
kurze lügen
bevor ich mit dem nächsten weiter mache
muss ich auf jeden fall einmal duschen
und business telefonate führen wenn
leute ihr wisst bescheid
bei den bildern da haben wir neuen
ordner hochgeladen hier also am besten
in der nähe von altenburg war mit
einen warmen ort legen zwei stunden
später ist dann auch mal der chor vorbei
und in der zeit musste ich einmal den
paketboten aufmachen und meinem nachbarn
und habe mir gedacht so ärgerlich jetzt
im bademantel und dann habe ich gemerkt
dass ich gut auch mit euch im bademantel
sprecher also wenn ich tausend vor
leuten zeigen dann können meine nachbarn
nicht aus ich bin halt die crazy
personen diesem haus schon wieder 13 07
und ich habe heute noch kein neues buch
angefangen aber manchmal geht es halt
ein paar wichtige dinge nämlich die
arbeit oder wissen sie was jetzt wo wir
uns michaels anekdoten aus dem leben
angeschaut haben wäre es doch gutes buch
als nächstes zu leben pelotons buch hat
160 seiten das von michael hatte 240 das
heißt das schaffe ich locker an einem
halben tag war luther
9 euro 99 kauft man muss ja hier mal die
you tube unterstützen bin eine richtige
leseratte jetzt bluten
die schmach ahmars verschwörung typische
lesezeit zwei stunden und 39 minuten
dann schauen wir heute noch viel mehr
steht euch eine kleine leseprobe kapitel
es war ein herrlicher tag in der welt
von friede ein paar sonnenstrahlen
kitzeln piloten an der nase und draußen
kreisten die chocobos um die wette was
sind chocobos eigentlich muss man das
lesen wie spa luton verlesen wurde
halunken schlenderte zum fenster hinüber
auf dem platz vor seinem haus wollte wie
immer das leben früher habe er sich
gefragt wo all die leute eigentlich so
plötzlich hergekommen waren die sich
hier niedergelassen haben na gut ich
werde jetzt erstmal essen und dann das
paar guten buch lesen wie es gerade die
idee gekommen dass ich jetzt einfach die
zeit stoppen werde und schaue wie lange
man denn wirklich braucht um das
paletten buch durchzulesen da wären wir
mal wieder beim thema entspannung
alles muss eine challenge sein und gott
2000 jahre später vielleicht kennt ihr
das ja schon aber ich habe gerade
entdeckt wenn ich dann hier so drauf
klären ist eine kleine zeichnung cool
ist das denn
kyu die stoppuhr sagt dass ich jetzt
eine stunde und 22 minuten gelesen habe
und ich bin bei 37 prozent das heißt ich
brauche ein bisschen länger als
angegeben
die schmack hamas verschwörung war
nachdem michael buchinger buch ich sag
mal ein ganz anderes genre auf keinen
fall dass es schlecht war es war halt
einfach ein jugendbuch ich habe gestern
nacht vorm schlafengehen noch etwas
gelesen und heute morgen dann zum
aufmachungen wir das noch mal geschnappt
und zu ende gelesen obwohl es 160 seiten
statt 240 seiten waren habe ich doch ein
bisschen länger gebraucht ich glaube
ungefähr dreieinhalb stunden ja ich kann
ich kann nicht viel mit minecraft anfang
trotzdem würde ich sagen dass man das
buch auch lesen kann
selbst wenn man nicht viel mit meinen
kindern und wenn man sowieso ein teil
juden fan ist ich glaube dann freut man
sich über jede zeile in der vernetzten
irgendwas sagt gut oder was macht wisst
ihr was ich möchte einfach wissen warum
eine glückliche beziehung kein zufall
ist jetzt gehe ich mal 899 sogar
günstiger als die beiden vor ich bin
gespannt für 890 kaufen
es ist jetzt halb eins also sollte ich
ja eigentlich so spätestens um halb drei
fertig werden ich bin gespannt
ich lese das buch jetzt seit ungefähr
einer halben stunde und ich bin echt
positiv überrascht ich glaube nicht ist
dann autor hinter steckt weil die
sprache sehr heiß einfach jugendsprache
es ist auf jeden fall cool aufgebaut
weil sie manchmal zusammen etwas
erzählen und jeder für sich einzeln und
das soll uns ja einfach nur im endeffekt
helfen den partner fürs leben zu finden
das ist doch ein tolles ziel
ich melde mich dann wieder wenn es
endlich ums thema sex geht eine 37
sekunden schmeckt heute es geht los sei
es etwas schönes erschafft die größte
intimität die zwischen zwei menschen
möglich ist und fühlt sich gut an und
sechs ist noch ein großes
geheimnisvolles abenteuern vor allem für
anfänger
ich hatte gerade einen gedanken wenn ich
jetzt überlege ich würde im land
kennenlernen und wir würden die
beziehung anfangen und dann würde ich
dieses buch sehen oder er würde mir von
diesem buch erzählen und dann würde ich
da durch blätter und dann lese ich wie
schön die beziehung ist und wie man über
alles spricht und wie liebt die sich
haben wir schon ein bisschen
eifersüchtig ich glaube es wäre schon
schwierig damit klarzukommen einfach mal
so gedanke am rande okay dass sony und
marcel buch hat mich auf jeden fall mehr
interessiert als die sparhammer
verschwörung ich finde es witzig wie sie
das buch geschrieben haben also
sie schreiben ganz osten sondern am ende
haha das mache ich auf der website
nachrichten sind irgendwas beziehung
pflegen war seltsam dass so ein buch zu
lesen aber gleichzeitig auch dann
irgendwie richtig locker heißt ihr euch
für beziehungsratgeber interessiert wäre
das auf jeden fall eine gute möglichkeit
eigentlich müsste ich mir die zehn
gebote holen kommt leider sehen das
gebot ist kindle kostet es 18 99
aber vielleicht werde ich danach voll
erfolgreich ja komm ich hole mir einfach
ich will die ganze zeit des bosque
porter buchen hinten zunächst einmal
möchte ich dir gratulieren dass du dich
zum kauf dieses exquisiten buches
entschlossen heißt ich liebe es jetzt
schon du solltest es nicht nur besitzen
sondern auch lesen vor allem begreifen
denn das was durch den folgenden seiten
an tipps informationen bekommen wirst
kann für dich von unschätzbarem wert und
nutzen seien bekanntermaßen so dass auf
dem buchmarkt eine unmenge an büchern
für männer gibt 1000 autoren wollen sind
was anschließend folgen münchen und
jeder sowieso los kommt ein rezept dafür
wie du garantiert wird und jede frau und
große scheiße auf deutschland ist ein
selbstbewusstes männer in einer vermehrt
an drucken gewordenen gesellschaft und
so was schmeckt der wein schlichten
presse pussys selten darauf geschossen
ich will hier nicht everybody's darling
sein
hier helfen und ich sage dir 1 dieses
buch wird der kollege wenn das männer
buch ist das hätte man irgendwie
vielleicht vorhersagen sollen bin
nämlich kein mangel das ist hätte auf
dem buch stehen können nur für männer
stieß es auf dem cover nicht okay ich
werde jetzt dieses buch lesen und euch
meine kommentare dazu geben ich hoffe
überhaupt nicht ganz lesen so als frauen
vielleicht werden wir auch einen cross
golf wünscht mir glück
ich musste heute zu einem termin und auf
dem weg entschied ich mich dann
plötzlich instagram zu öffnen
denn obwohl ich ja gerade beim die talks
bin und dann war ich auf twitter wieder
auf instagram und dann war ich wieder
auf twitter bin ich vom team nach hause
gekommen dann habe ich zwei stunden gut
geschlagen mit social media
dass kollege habe ich gestern weiter
gelesen und es ist schon witzig wenn man
kollegen lustig findet man diesen ganzen
sexismus kram nicht aushalten kann dann
wird man aber auch dieses buch nicht
aushalten
ich überlege gerade ein video in der
küche zu drehen obwohl ich mir
vorgenommen habe in diesen sieben tagen
außer diesem video nichts anderes zu
machen
man will es kaum glauben aber
tatsächlich aber jetzt doch angefangen
noch ein video zu drehen es kommt
allerdings erst nach diesem ich würde
euch gerne schon verraten worum es geht
ich zeige euch mal ganz kurz ein
ausschnitt was kann es bloß sein und
warum habe ich so ein riesen donath auf
dem kopf all diese fragen beantwortet
uns jetzt der boss der alpha bus
unterschied während man im buch
wenn ihr das zweifelnde ruf verstummt
weil der bericht folgt eine blutprobe
zur brust ich habe die boss
transformationen nun hinter mich
gebracht und kommt zu einem fazit es ist
sonntagabend und ich habe jetzt die
letzten sieben tage nur bücher von
youtube angelesen und weniger am handy
gahan ab und zu gab es natürlich
rückschläge und dann bin ich irgendwie
doch auf instagram entweder gelandet
aber im großen und ganzen habe ich mich
eigentlich nur die ganze woche mit
meinem kindle beschäftigt und gelesen
kollegen buch war tatsächlich besser als
erwartet ich bin überrascht dass es
unter den ganzen büchern keins gab wo
ich gesagt hat das kann ich nicht mehr
lesen also jedes war auf jeden fall so
gut dass man es lesen konnte bei den
boss geboten musste man ganz schön auch
ein auge zudrücken wenn es explosion so
aber gleichzeitig hatte ich das gefühl
dass er sehr oft sehr gute sachen gesagt
also auch sehr nette sachen ich meine
ich bin motiviert mein leben als afa
boss fortzuführen
ihr habt ihr gewinn ist das kindle ins
wasser geworfen habe aber das hat ihn
nicht ausgemacht einfach abtrocknen und
dann ging es auch wieder säcken in der
video beschreibung für die auf jeden
fall alle links zu den büchern und zum
kinde
und was mir sonst vielleicht noch so
einfällt bei dem dramatischen start
dieses videos brauchen es auf jeden fall
etwas positives und die ganzen sache
abzuschließen ein fazit was euch im
herzen erblühen lässt ist aufgefallen
dass ich in dieser woche echt gerne
zurückgezogen habe für stunden und
einfach etwas gelesen habe und gerade
mit dem grünen star hat mich das echt
gut gefallen dass ich mit dem kindle
halt einfach besser lesen kann als jetzt
eine mal und jetzt bekommt ihr meine
ehrliche meinung zu youtuber die bücher
schreiben das funktioniert eigentlich
ganz gut ich gerade zu den leuten die
dachten auch jetzt noch einen youtube
plötzlich ein buch schreiben nicht
vorstellen konnte dass es gut sein wird
wenn man das nicht so als seine ganze
lebensaufgabe gemacht sondern
so nebenbei aber selbst wenn youtuber
hilfe von autoren bekommen das buch zu
schreiben ist es doch schön dass man
wieder die jugend zum lesen bringen also
alle die das öffentlich kritisieren wenn
ein youtuber ein buch herausbringen
ganz ehrlich es ist nicht so teuer wie
plätzen im supermarkt ein magazin
gekauft und das hat schon 97 gekostet
also im verhältnis sind bücher wirklich
jetzt nicht die welt und ich finde man
sollte niemals auch für neue wege zu
beschreiten denn selbst wenn die leute
wir sagen ja du bist buchautor genau ist
es keinen grund schon vorher aufzugeben
wenn du was trotzdem gerne machen den
ersten bücher richtig scheiße werden und
das dritte aber richtig gut du bist doch
der weg ist das ziel jedes ziel ist das
zählen und mein ziel ist es jetzt weil
handy zu holen und vielleicht nicht so
viel mehr auf instagram und twitter und
sowas umzuhängen dafür mal wieder was zu
leben so kinder das war zu mir ich hab
euch hat das video gefallen und ich
wünsche euch noch eine ganz tolle woche
und wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten
video
ich find's schön dass ich immer raus
gehe als ob ich auf einer bühne wäre
oder sonne mit nein